I have five minutes to do this but you
have five minutes
Indonesia is home to the world's most
populous island this video this video
was supposed to be easy
me Mommy MA
time to go to bed me mommy because I am
really tired from rendering
well everyone is working hard today I'd
like to take a moment and talk to you
guys about facts facts helps shape your
worldview and it's only more facts over
time that helped change or evolve your
worldview in fact I was researching for
a video the other day and I ended up
down a deep Wikipedia rabbit hole and I
discovered a bunch of random very
interesting facts and so what I'd like
to do is share with you some of the most
fascinating facts that I discovered well
on this journey half of the families
living in New York City speak a language
in addition to or other than English in
the home you're talking probably like 3
million people I didn't think it would
be that high number 2 despite China
having over 1.3 billion people their
population is expected to go down
slightly down to 1.2 billion only
despite being the 31st largest country
by landmass Nigeria is the seventh
largest country by population what's
even more fascinating is that their
population is expected to double by 2050
double now what's even more crazy is
that with this growth you get this
really really skewed population growth
chart that I didn't see in any other
country people in Nigeria age 0 to 4
make up the largest section of the
populous in that country and each older
age group successively makes up less and
less of the population than the one
before it when it comes to land mass
Russia is king and I think everyone
knows that but I don't think everyone
really appreciates just how big
that country is larger than the entire
continent of Antarctica it's twice as
big as the number-two landmass country
Canada it's greater than the entire land
mass of Pluto this video this video was
supposed to be easy this was supposed to
be a super simple video wrong today is
what the end of day of Wednesday and
this video is going up on Saturday
that's a merman I don't know exactly how
much work Sam did today and I know Clint
was working on the steak shots of flying
steaks this shot that I was working on I
was like okay I'll have this shot done
in maybe two hours I spend the entire
day on it and I'm not done
at some point the camera moves so a lot
of like the clean plate and a lot of the
different place don't actually line up
with each other so it's like manually
lining them up and then it's just like
compositing in like puzzle pieces to
make everything feel seamless dude I'm
slinging steaks at this imaginary
backboard trying to get it to slide down
this meat chute into this little meat
basket I've been working on this since
10:30 this morning I have 27 minutes
before I leave today if I can get my
meat bouncing off this backboard and
sliding down this slide then I'd
consider the day a success I am building
this dynamic meat machine in cinema 4d
which I built in real life the sky is
the limit you're only limited by your
mind right you can do anything in cinema
40 it's the best but man oh man is my
work cut out for me this is some tough
stuff I I have I have a lot ahead of me
I've been working all day just trying to
get this thing right right now I feel
like I'm waiting through quicksand
eventually I'll be an Olympic swimmer
this ax chops all these zombies in half
meat flies against this backboard to
this back border here wise against this
backboard and drops down onto this
little chute right here and it goes down
the chute from here and then into this
little meat bucket and they all go down
into here it's got to be like 80 steaks
every every little bit is a stretch with
hand forget hand hurts good thing I'm
using a pendant my hand still hurts
Oh what would your expectations starting
this to finish the shot today I expected
to finish this shot today I am is a
silly expectation no I got to leave in
27 minutes I've been a acapella group
we've been in rehearsal for actual
Christmas oh man you guys are going hard
you're practicing in July yeah it's
gonna get it together so this works I
like this it's that the wind is blowing
my camera away no but that doesn't make
any sense
in 1910 55% of the population of America
was living in rural areas the total
population of the country 100 million
meaning that 55 million people lived in
rural areas
compare that with 2010 where only 20% of
the population lives in rural America
now the thing that I found most
interesting about this was that the same
number of people still live in rural
America 55 million meaning that the
growth from 100 million in 1910 to 325
million in 2010 all took place in urban
area I'm not exactly sure what to make
of that fact but I think it means in
part that there's less people moving
from rural America to urban America than
we think and there's just simply more
and more growth happening in urban areas
number seven Indonesia is home to the
world's most populous island that of
Java no not the coffee
Java Island has over a hundred and forty
million people on it 140 million
including the capital city of Jakarta
which including the metropolitan area
has around 30 million people making it
the third most populous metro area on
the globe on an island even crazier
still the number one most populous
metropolitan area with 38 billion people
is also in East Asia
it's Tokyo in Japan now what's crazier
still is that the top 10 most populous
metropolitan areas on the globe the
entire globe which have a combined
population of 2.75 billion people are
all on the continent of Asia all of them
can I sit here know the top five
countries by landmass in order
Russia Canada China
the United States and Brazil make up
fifty two point five million square
kilometers combined and take up 35% of
the entire land mass of the globe not
including the oceans 38 percent of the
population lives in the South no not
that South the southern United States
you might think it would be the
northwest or the west or even the
Midwest but song it's the south son
China has 1.3 billion people and that's
not why this is important the United
States by comparison has 325 million
people that's not all so why this is
important why that's important is
because they have the same exact
landmass almost nine point five million
square kilometers meaning that there's
an average of 148 people per square
kilometer in China versus just 36 here
comfort class legroom around here I
gotta say nice subscribe Judy I don't
know
it's just blowing wait
reset the seat reset oh okay okay okay
okay hard boot five minutes to do this
five minutes we're talking about these
other things very funny moment
no I'm climbing south sister Oh what are
you planning the volcano who's sister
it's no one's sister red it's a Southern
which volcano sister the southern one
that's the middle ones sister which town
is this near this is near bend four
minutes left
no you're actually down to three minutes
now oh yeah try and pay attention okay
so what sort of things are you wanted to
get from sorry on the move train plane
I'm trying to move this plane into
position and then you're gonna get line
to stop me with the Cuba you know maybe
have I can say so why don't you have
hiking stick yeah because I didn't kind
of a camper you think I needed hiking
sticks until you're wrong I climbed
Baldy with Jam yeah my feet nearly came
off who would you have a pair of hiking
sticks first doesn't everybody
oh you're only down to two minutes so do
you know where you're gonna be getting
the program I'm gonna put it I'm gonna
put it right in zoom when you're
climbing the South sister Rudy's sister
Oh Rin okay I'm almost I'm almost at
once I get the first piece of the puzzle
in place
this has to be exact when you're what
are you coming back can we expect you on
Monday
No why aren't you gonna be here on
Monday because I'm at an office on right
are you gonna be in Monday I'm gonna be
in Portland you're doing oh I'm so
jealous I'm gonna be in Portland hanging
out with my good friend Tyler who called
me up he's like hey do you wanna hike a
volcano
like that's just Tyler I love it I have
50 seconds but I think I think I'm gonna
make it it's gonna be here Crispo I'd
Christmas miracle all of this was wrong
that Ren you would you misses the 30
seconds you would like you would you
would was like this isn't the way to do
it no this is it this is it
shoes oh wow ten seconds ten seconds man
three two one place to plate
oh you did get it place oh snap Ren it
worked oh my god it did work
it turned out real thank you this was
surprisingly challenging to make it look
that seamless it's like you can get the
patchwork put together reasonably
quickly but actually taking it from like
just patchwork they pull on stainless
and visit invisible effects it's like
well under love here's why this shot is
now challenging with the axe blade over
just something in the background that
still it's easy enough just to take a
still frame of that put it over the axe
during those few frames where the actors
is obscuring it move on his arm moves
there is no original clean footage of
his arm in that position so what I'm
gonna have to do is literally recreate
his arm his hand his chest his stomach
his leg even for those few frames where
they're obscured and hopefully make it
believable enough that just by watching
him you don't realize anything wrong I
did have an idea on how to make this
easier when I was on set this I'm just
saying this could have been an easier
shot they're so easy I know what the
shot takes 20 minutes to render your
you're ignoring the hard part of the
shot no it's done no that's done to be
honest he's not picking apart the arm up
Clint trust me on some of these things
I've spent a day and a half with this
one shot there's pops there's an object
pump now there are not all these pops
did you suck see I didn't see them
amazing a lot of these attempt it took
me four days man for friggin days
what is it is currently 4:30 p.m. on
Friday and this video is supposed to go
live tomorrow at noon which means it's
supposed to be done in just a few hours
and ready to be exported uploading today
I'm working on the know I have to get
the air and air put it at 8:30 which
means I have to leave it's 7:00 tonight
yes
it will be like filling yeah absolutely
that's why you keep working we'll see
let's see if there's a link in the
description
you know we succeeded if there's not
also Loki thanks to Wikipedia for being
with pedia this isn't no way sponsored
but everyone that I know including
myself and you probably have derived
some form of benefit and information
from Wikipedia now they don't use
advertisement they depend on donations
give them a buck
you can donate money to which people
that's how the whole site works dude